mike tarico joins us now hey mike how
are you buddy
hi how are we doing
oh we're doing great on this friday
morning and the lamar jackson interview
i'm looking forward to watching all of
it you know an opportunity to sit down
and really get to know a guy that we
don't know much about what was your big
takeaway from having an extended
opportunity to talk to the second year
quarterback
yeah that was one of the reasons uh to
do this also you know uh patrick mahomes
i think he's gotten
the understandable ton of attention
after last year's mvp season baker
mayfield when he came in but lamar
jackson for a guy who won the heisman
trophy his first uh in his first couple
of years at louisville and then has come
to the nfl has not gotten as much
attention and perhaps it kind of is in
lockstep with baltimore for whatever
reason over the years the ravens have
been in the shadow of pittsburgh within
their own division there
but certainly not the play i don't know
why national attention does not fall to
the ravens more often so
lamar is a very uh
warm
easy to like type of player and person
i'll give you an example let's start the
anecdote here so you remember the
pittsburgh game they played lamar is
running to the sidelines and a
photographer female photographer's there
and lamar ends up making contact with
her knocks her down stops and tries to
help her up before going back to the
huddle so the next day lamar hops on
social media and
on twitter direct messages dms the
photographer to make sure she's doing
okay
that's the kind of guy and person lamar
is and that's what i found
around him and i'll tell you this mike
baltimore was always a place of big
personalities
lamar is the guy who's in the middle of
it all now in that ravens locker room
even though he's only been there two
years
and they were thrilled to get him when
they sprang back into round one with the
32nd pick five quarterbacks taken in
2018. mike right now i i hate to say
this in all due respect to baker
mayfield and josh allen but lamar
jackson is the clear number one based
upon performances in 2019
that's exactly right uh when you look at
it record wise you look at what's
happened how it's played out
and you remember this team turned over
a team that was quarterbacked by a super
bowl champion in joe flacco
to lamar jackson who had a completely
different skill set
and what they've done and they made the
decision in the draft room that day when
if we're gonna go here this is john
harbaugh ozzie newsome at the time eric
acosta we're gonna have to go all in and
all in means the type of offensive
lineman the type of running backs be a
more tight end based offense which they
always were good at and they have and
that has allowed lamar jackson to take
his college skill set
and make the jump over to the nfl
a little bit easier than perhaps the
other quarterbacks who come in as a
rookie without as much talent around
them so this has been a really unique
organizational decision and i fully
credit the ravens for going down a road
that was right there in front of them
but was a difficult road to make the
turn and they did so good good on them
for doing it i'm excited that they've
done it and i i've enjoyed watching how
lamar has developed as a player as well
he wants to be a passer he does not want
to be known as the running quarterback
he's very proud of that five touchdown
pass effort against miami he wants to be
the guy to distribute the ball downfield
not just run the ball effectively
and we've seen more and more mike nfl
coaches realizing that what a
quarterback does well at college is what
you should have him do at the nfl level
use the same offense adapt the same
concepts and it's working so far for the
ravens but the one big caveat that we've
discussed mike and i'm sure you
discussed with lamar jackson earlier
this week at some point those hits he
takes right you can only take so many of
those before you're not going to be able
to get up how concerned is he that he's
taking too much physical abuse the way
that he plays the game
well i even posed a question to him mike
and it's something that you're a witness
to i said
i sit next to uh in our sunday screening
room for football in america tony gunty
on my left rodney harrison on my right
and at some point any one of the three
of us say
man this kid's gonna get hurt he can't
he can't take all these hits so lamar's
like hey i can i'm okay he's like i'm
smart about it too
he's he's being smart about getting
himself out of bounds getting himself
down but he feels like the way he's
built and for whatever reason i don't
know if it's our memories of him when he
won the heisman at louisville
he has a look he looks a little slighter
slighter than he is he is thick uh he
he's tall he's 6-1 he's powerful
and he has that in him so he feels like
he can take that kind of
extra hits that other quarterbacks
aren't getting guys who are pure pocket
passers and still be okay but he also
sees his game as evolving as to not just
being a runner but being a complete
quarterback so when i asked him directly
he said i'm good i can do this i can get
through this i'm not taking too many
hits so time will answer that question
but that's where his mind is and
look we'll see sunday what do the
patriots do best better than anybody in
the modern nfl they take away what you
do best what the ravens do best is lamar
jackson running so will they make lamar
jackson throw the ball to win the game
can they get to that point that'll be
the fascinating thing to watch on sunday
night
and there's a very healthy amount of
dislike between the ravens and the
patriots is the first time lamar
jackson's going to see the patriots did
you get the impression that he's gotten
the memo that this is one of the teams
that the ravens collectively hate
i i'm sure that's easy to figure out
just by being around baltimore i'm sure
he's got that i will say this he has as
you would imagine immense respect for
tom brady and looking up tom brady and
calling the goat and all that mike i
think he had the sound bite slash quote
of the first half of the season for me
he said tom brady when he's in the
pocket it's like he's on vacation
and he talks about wanting to be that
calm in the pocket and now just think of
that visual i love it and that's where
the kid's aspiring to go so it gives you
a mindset of where he's going forward
but also a little bit of his personality
as well he's just pure honest uh very
very likable young man and i i hope that
we continue to see him grow because look
these are as you were alluding to
earlier with mayfield and rosen and all
the other guys and all these drafts that
these these are the feature quarterbacks
of the week and we saw garoppolo play
well last night and kyler murray every
time we watch kyler murray go okay you
know what's getting better getting
better getting better
this is where the league is going it's
an exciting group of young men and
lamar's right there in the middle of it
yeah and lamar's right in the middle of
the mvp conversation and i'd say he's
one of the three or four leading
candidates right now mike he has to keep
doing what he's done he has to stay
healthy but
he and you know and they never really
give you a definition of what mvp means
but when you look at value to the ravens
if we're gonna if we're gonna base it on
value to your team it is clear that this
ravens team wouldn't be anywhere close
to five and two without him
it's it's a great conversation to get
people
sparked and inspired make him do a
deeper dive mike uh seven yards just
under seven yards per carry average
his before contact yardage before
anybody touches him speed ability play
design is 4.2 yards that's what the
league averages per run so he's getting
the league average before anybody
touches him
great pro football focus numbers on
lamar jackson that they give you that
insight he's 10th in the league in
rushing his passer rating is higher than
phillip rivers he's in the middle of the
pack so if you get a guy who could be
top 10 in rushing and top 12 or 14 and
passer rating all rolled into one
yeah you're right with an 11-win team
that would garner
mvp conversation and i think important
night two for the ravens mike at home
against the patriots obviously the
patriots are undefeated the steelers
have a tough game against indianapolis
they didn't set the world up fire in the
first part of the game against miami
they are home for indy but if indy a
good team goes in there and beats
pittsburgh and baltimore has a chance to
take a three-game lead
in the loss column
on the steelers
that would be significant all of a
sudden if if pittsburgh wins at home and
then the patriots beat baltimore now
this division race becomes tight for the
second half of the season i think a very
pivotal week here for the ravens in the
nfc the afcc uh north north of race
hey mike and let's broaden it just a
little bit as well because the ravens
are a serious contender to be the number
two seed in the afc and get the bye week
that goes along with it with the chiefs
now
at five and three
patrick mahomes who knows what's gonna
happen with him will we see him this
sunday if he doesn't play this sunday
they lose the vikings they fall to five
and four you start to get separation
there and it could be the ravens two
seed patriots one seed and if the ravens
would happen to win sunday night they
can start thinking about possibly being
the one seed
that's a long way away but you're right
when you start thinking of it that way
and same through the winter of the afc
south
they're also going to be that
conversation for the two seed as well i
think the kansas city thing is really
fascinating already three losses at home
uh a team you know so well the vikings
coming into town to play them at
arrowhead it could be possible that
through half the season plus nine weeks
that kansas city could have four home
losses that would be stunning stuff but
it is a possibility and you start to
look back okay have they beaten anybody
at home yeah they beat baltimore at home
so they they hold that for tiebreaker
purposes but i think while the matchups
may not be super sexy here these couple
of games that minnesota kansas city game
the sunday night game
are going to have a long way to
determining how the afc shakes out when
we uh when we get done with this
let's flip it over to the nfc in the
last minute or two that i have you here
who do you think the best team in that
conference is right now
i can make a really good argument in my
head for
all three of the group of san francisco
new orleans
and green bay
if you start to ask me i know i'm trying
to take the recency bias away just
having watched san francisco where their
defense maybe gave you a little bit of a
question of their dominance by giving up
25 to arizona
but your questions about jimmy garoppolo
i think are eased after you watch the
way he played last night so
let's keep san francisco where they
where you thought they were before the
thursday night game
that new orleans defensive front is
terrific and right now with brees back
healthy coming off a bye this week going
into you know arrested and healthy herb
breeze
i like the way new orleans stacks up for
the second half of the season i think
because of the difficulty of the nfc
north would be a little bit tougher for
green bay to get to the top
so that's dancing around the question i
think if he had forced me for an answer
right now i would begrudgingly give you
new orleans but i would say uh
incomplete would be the great there i
think we need to see the second half of
the season
it is going to be a heck of a scramble
in the nfc for playoff spots for bye
weeks for the number one seed because
you don't want to go to new orleans in
january you don't want to go to lambeau
field in january san francisco is going
to want to be right at home and force
those teams to come to them all right my
great stuff the lamar jackson interview
available on the mike trico podcast and
the nbc sports youtube channel at
youtube.com nbc sports mike thanks for
some of your time on a friday morning
enjoy notre dame and virginia tech
tomorrow and we'll see you sunday for
football night in america
see you bright and early sunday morning
mike thanks have a great weekend pal
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports